hello today we're going to look at rwkv
which in its own words is Reinventing
rnns for the Transformer ERA this is a
very interesting project and a very
interesting model architecture because
it has some properties of Transformers
notably it's a model architecture that's
very scalable in terms of training so
you can stack it really deep and you can
still train it and also you can
parallelize training at the same time it
avoids the quadratic memory bottleneck
that Transformers have by essentially
being an RNN it's kind of a recurrent
neural network in the sense that during
inference you can compute the output
step by step and always have a constant
memory because everything is put into a
hidden State we're going to look at how
these two things come together and what
the trade-offs are between the two the
project is also very interesting because
it's been largely he developed by one
person or by just very few people who
have worked on this and then compare
this to entire corporations that are
pouring their Human Resources into
Transformers and still the results are
that this model in some cases not in all
cases but in some cases can be very
comparable in terms of performance with
Transformers with really big
Transformers and as I said it is
scalable which so far rnns have been
lacking
we'll go over the paper we'll go over
the architecture and see what's actually
happening right here I have some of my
own thoughts and you know just opinions
on this and I hope you're with me but
first let's
let me show you this fully connected is
a conference it's by weights and biases
it's a one day event and it has pretty
cool speakers so the not only the
co-founders of Weights advices
themselves but the co-founder of Lang
chain is there the co-founder of kaggle
is there Richards soccer from you.com is
their chip yen is there of clay pot
there's so many people right here and so
many cool speakers and as I said if you
are in around the San Francisco area go
give that event a a visit if you want
I'm gonna use uh put a link in the promo
code into the description of this video
that will make the tickets cheaper so
the tickets will be 49 bucks instead of
what you see right here so that's going
to be on June the 7th don't forget that
June the 7th in San Francisco it's an
in-person event has a Max Capacity so
grab it now
that's it thanks debates and biases for
also giving me this opportunity and you
know also giving this to you it's very
cool
so
rwkv it stands for
let me not screw this up receptive
receptance receptance R is for
receptance W is for weight K is for key
and V is for Value these describe the
different elements of the model
architecture and will go through that
will go through it so what are we
dealing with we're dealing with a model
that you can use for lots of things but
we're mainly dealing with a model that
in the instance it is outlined here is
for language modeling by language
modeling we simply mean we have a piece
of text
and what we want the model to predict is
the next set the next tokens or the next
word in the text so from here predict
this thing then from here predict this
thing and so on Transformers are usually
used in this manner notably I would
stick the entire prefix here into a big
Transformer and the Transformer would
spit out the next step it will do that
in a form that we call causal attention
which essentially means that every piece
in the text right here so every token
can attend to all the other tokens that
are before it so all the other tokens
that come in front of it would have be
would be inputs to that token and using
attention that results in a quadratic in
a quadratic requirement of compute and
memory now if you can see there the if
every token attends to its back it's
like T times T half minus one or
something like this
interactions that need to be considered
so t squared in expectation
and
no yes maybe
yeah that makes a bad sense
um so Transformers naturally have a
limit because if you add one token then
you always add a memory requirement of
of T and so very quickly that scales uh
to be out of proportion so their power
is traded off by the fact that they can
only consider a limited set of tokens at
a time recurrent neural networks trade
this off recurrent neural networks if
they have to do something like this if
they have to have an input and then
predict the next thing what they'll do
is they'll just start here
then they'll put something into a hidden
State like a little memory I'm going to
represent that as a box people have
forgotten how rnns work I figured uh
like a few years ago I could have talked
about rnns and every one of you would
have known what I'm talking about and
then Transformers are kind of the new
thing and now it's more like I have to
say I don't even have to mention stuff
as a Transformer
um but I do have to conversely explain
RNN so it would put whatever it learns
into a memory like this Hidden book this
box right here is the memory then from
that it would consume the memory and it
would consume this thing and it would
build a new memory and then it would
consume that memory and it would consume
the next input it would build a new
memory so it does this step by step and
it can always you can drop the old
memory so you can forget about the old
memory because all you need uh haha pun
intended to go forward from here on out
is that current memory so you do step by
step and you always save stuff into the
memory into the hidden state or whatever
you want to call it so rnns have this
really great property that they only
require a constant memory in order to do
inference how however the individual the
individual inference step for example
when we are here we have that memory we
predict the next
um the next token from it so we predict
the next this thing right here we can
only consider the memory and the
previous token that's all we cannot
explicitly consider any token that is in
the way back because everything goes
through that hidden state
and that bottleneck has usually been one
of the downfalls for rnns there is a
problem of Vanishing gradients there are
a couple of other problems that you
can't just compress information into
that one hidden State plus rnns have
been notoriously hard to train because
the inference always requires this
step-by-step thing which means you have
to do back propagation through time
which gets is part of the vanishing
gradient problem but also means that you
can't parallelize the training in a
Transformer I can input a token oopsie a
token sequence of 50 tokens and that
gives me 50 training examples which I
can train all at the same time because
of the causal attention mask in an RNN
if I have a sequence of 50 tokens I can
still only train one token loss at a
time because I can't infer everything at
the same time
or wkv is going to strike a trade-off in
the middle of those two things and in a
sense so people ask or I asked is this a
Transformer more is it an RNN more and
I've come to the conclusion
it's a con net and I'm going to I'm
going to explain my reasoning and they
they also refer to that by the way um
it's it's not like I found out something
uh great right here but in the most
basic sense you can think of this thing
as a convolutional network
um across a one-dimensional sequence of
of tokens
that's that's going to be my statement
and we'll go through it so they give a
bit of an introduction right here on
what it what this means and what I
essentially just said Transformers scale
quadratically with sequence length R and
ends exhibit linear scaling which is
very beneficial very advantageous the
rwkv model combines the efficient
parallelizable training of Transformers
with the efficient inference of rnns so
it's like almost two modes between
between which you can switch around
uh they say they have a linear attention
mechanism and as I said they formulate
the model either as a Transformer or as
an RNN that linear attention mechanism
is something that we're going to focus
on in just a bit
um because
it's not it's not their fault because
people have been doing it before them
but I think it really stretches the word
attention and what what it means I think
it stretches that to like a point where
I don't agree anymore calling it
attention
um but again they are not the first
people
kind of doing that so I'm not going to
hold them to to account right here
foreign
they say this is the first
non-transformer architecture that to be
scaled to tens of billions of parameters
so one of the properties of this thing
is really you can scale it you can scale
it and you can train it in parallel
which also means you can pump a lot of
data into it and that's very
advantageous and there is a lot to be
said here about maybe maybe it's not
that much the architecture we're dealing
with but more you know good models are
simply models with architectures that
are scalable so it's not maybe right
that's a hypothesis like how much of the
performance of something like gpt4 is
due to the fact that it is a Transformer
and how much is due to the fact just
that is a scalable architecture you can
pump a lot of data into we don't know
yet too well how those things exactly
trade off but there is good argument to
be made that hey if you can find some
other architecture which just scales
really well then you know you might as
well reach the same performance
um this is a an in a complexity a
asymptotic complexity table on the
different ways of doing attention
mechanisms so the Transformer is that
classic mechanism as we said it needs
quadratic time in t Big T is the
sequence length of the sequence we're
processing and then in terms of space it
needs a little bit more but the leading
term is also this t squared right here
the D is the dimension I believe of the
of the embeddings of the Hidden spaces
which is usually a constant Factor
across all of these things
there there are various trade-offs like
reformer and so on performer a lot of
these they do approximations to the
original Transformer attention mechanism
and it's also notable to say that rwkv
is not an approximate attention or
anything like this it doesn't try to
approximate the original attention it
replaces it with a different mechanism
of considering the past
so what does that mechanism look like
um
yet
let's yeah let's let's go into it so
maybe yeah this is this is smart let's
first look at this here if you've uh
been in in deep learning and or old like
me you remember this this is an lstm
this is a long shorter memory cell
um from back when before attention was a
thing so this was one of the main ways
people built rnn's recurrent neural
networks uh that would actually somewhat
avoid that Vanishing gradient problem
and could learn to remember things for a
long time the idea behind lstms is that
you have
your the hidden you have two hidden
States
if I'm correct
um am I correct yes so you have two
hidden States this C and this H H being
the real hidden State and you have a lot
of these uh gating mechanisms so
what the gating mechanisms do it's often
represented like this here this is an
element wise product
so what you would do is you would given
get in a hidden State you would get in
an input you put the input through some
sort of computation neural networks
non-linearities yada yada yada and then
you'd have some result right here which
would be a vector right and then the
question is obviously you can compute an
output from that at this particular time
step but the question is how should the
next hidden State look like
and the idea behind lstms and similar
architectures is that we're going to
take the last hidden state
sorry we're going to take the last
hidden state
and we're going to update it
in a if in a really basic RNN we would
just kind of replace the hidden state or
we would maybe add the two together and
then for a propagated but what an lstm
does very interestingly is introduces
these these Gates so what we'll do is
we'll have something like a forget gate
and the forget gate is simply
a binary or not a binary but it's a a
obviously
continuous but we can imagine it as a
binary Vector where just it's a mask
the values between 0 and 1 and wherever
it's zero there is an element-wise
multiplication wherever it's zero this
hidden state is going to get forgotten
and then the new state is going to be
updated at that particular point so
there is a gonna be a forget gate
there's also going to be maybe a gate
right here that tells which things of
the Hidden state to even remember right
that's also a binary Vector maybe only
these things and so the network itself
can control which parts of the
information it wants to remember which
parts it wants to forget and which parts
it wants to retain and then the new
hidden state is going to be sort of an
addition of these masked inputs and then
that goes on
in order to do that there's a lot of
computation needed as you see right here
and in particular I want to draw your
attention uh to one fact the next hidden
States for example if you take this H
right here the next hidden state is
always going to be some non-linear
function
um for example this is a sigmoid I
believe it's a non-linearity or a tan H
or something like this of something here
like of the CT the CT in itself is a
linear combination but a linear
combination of this this in its turn
again is a
non-linearity and then a linear
combination of the things and this
ultimately is the last hidden state so
you can see from the last hidden state
to the next hidden State we pass at
least two non-linearities right and
there you see this sequential stepwise
nature of things it's always it's always
you have to compute
the step then you have to
compute The Next Step based on this step
and the outputs are non-linearly related
so there is no way you can like
jump a few ahead or take five steps
together or something like this because
they're non-linear it's not like linear
functions linear functions compute
really easily right
um non-linear functions that are stacked
where every next thing needs the first
thing as an input those are really not
parallelizable not
like aggregatable or anything like this
so that's the problem with rnns if
they're formulated like this
they also go a little bit into the
attention mechanism which I guess by now
I don't have to explain Too Much Anymore
there is a query and a key Matrix both
are produced from the data so the data
enters and three matrices are produced
queries keys and values will do an outer
product between the queries and keys
which is defines this quadratic
interaction so every token can attend to
every other token uh sometimes it would
then mask this with the causal mask with
the upper or lower triangular Matrix
then build a soft Max across that so the
softmax essentially converts some values
so let's say your values are this
positive negative negative positive
would convert that into a distribution
we can interpret it as a probability
distribution or you can interpret it as
essentially whatever you want but you
can it defines where to put the
attention right it defines which things
I should look at like this one and this
one a little bit I guess that's why it's
called attention because it defines the
weights in by which I aggregate
information so it dynamically allocates
attention to some of these values right
here rather than others that's what
attention means to me in it's in the
sense how it's described and that's why
I said the term is stretched a bit far
you can write attention in a in a
different way and you can decompose it
recur recurrently
um almost like an RNN so you can
decompose attention computation and this
is done in parts to also get around the
memory bottleneck however you trade it
off with computation right if you
compute these things in sequences you
have to compute them sequentially where
you could just compute them in parallel
by doing a big outer product matrix
multiplication so you do trade-off time
and memory here and by the way you have
to remember all of these things you can
sum them I guess
I mean any matrix multiplication you can
probably
do that with never mind
you can decompose the attention
computation
the same one as above in a way like this
so I have the outer product of just
pair of keys and queries I raise that to
D I have the exponential of that that's
part of that soft Max computation
ultimately I divide by the the sum of
these values so that's the softmax
operator and then I multiply the value
at that particular location so you can
see here this part here defines a weight
and V is the value so it's a weighted
sum of the values
now we come to attention free
Transformers which is a piece of work
that this paper takes a lot of
inspiration from attention free
Transformers try to go about this in the
same way as attention but they say hey
can we reformulate this this formula up
here the one that we saw
can we reformulate this and
just turn it into something that doesn't
need that whole quadratic memory uh
Shaban
and they come up and say if we don't
have to do the outer product up here
this outer product
if we don't have to do these Outdoor
Products
um then that would
sort of mean that we don't have this
token the token every token can attend
to every other token interactions
anymore which means we don't have that
quadratic thing anymore and therefore
um
we
would you know we could save a lot of
memory so they replace the interactions
between query and key they replace that
and they say let's let's not even
compute the query we'll just compute a
key for each token so we're now only
producing matrices K and V okay no
queries
instead we'll have these W's right here
the W's are learned so w is a learned
Matrix so not a not computed from the
data
but learned and it just learns how
tokens interact with each other
what does it mean it means that I just
have a matrix
instead of size T by T and in there one
two three four five one two three four
five and in this Matrix there's gonna be
a number like
seven okay and that means that the
interaction that the weight the
attention weight essentially of that
token one has with respect to token two
so how much is token one gonna
attend to token two let's assume it's
not causally masked is seven
okay that that's that's that it's the
same for all the sequences you all you
just say well the first token is always
going to attend seven to the second
token all the same it's one set of
learned parameters and therefore you can
this is just now a multiplication by a
constant essentially
now that just defines a fixed attention
um which is a bit too little so the
fixed attention is not flexible enough
before we had completely Dynamic
attention and now we go to completely
fixed attention that is just learned
across the whole data set and the
authors there said wisely hey you know
it isn't it is the fact that
depending on the current data point we
might need to look back further or we
might need to change that attention
pattern a little bit
so they say okay how about we simply add
the keys here
so the keys are values that are computed
from the data right so now the data can
Define essentially an offset to that so
maybe for one data point it's eight
important because it says Ah token one
should really look a token two and for
another data point the K is negative one
so this is six right here that depresses
that a little bit so there's a
modulation in that attention pattern
there is one across the data set which
is fixed and then on top of that there's
a modulation given by each individual
data point uh to modulate that however
the interaction is not multiplicative as
it is in the Transformer attention that
you see up here it's additive which is
in a sense a lot less
powerful because the multiplicative
interaction really defines you know when
two things are close and when two things
are far apart between keys and queries
whereas here
we just
modify a little bit that fixed that
fixed pattern right here
however that fixed pattern can't take
into account so token one
if it decides on its K value it can't
take into account the what token 2 is it
simply says I'm the word cat I should
probably really look three words behind
me
um that's really important
whereas the original attention can
decide I'm the word cat and I should
probably really look at words that
relate to fish or fur or uh or sleeping
like that those words those kinds of
words really interest me and that's how
it would craft its query and that's what
it would be retrieved from the keys of
the other words whereas here it can just
say well I'm cat I should probably look
three words behind me seems really good
I hope you can see how this is
kind of less powerful than the original
attention but it is more scalable
again you see what it defines is
essentially this part right here
is a weight so you have a weighted sum
of the values
lastly
we have this paper right here so it
formulates the attention mechanism it
says yeah but here what we still need to
do is we still need to learn that
interaction Matrix which crucially also
means it's still limited by T it's still
limited by
um you know sort of a fixed size we
can't we can't go bigger than that and
what they say now is how about we don't
learn this Matrix all we learn is a
vector all we learn is the vector w
and the vector W
it's the same for all and it defines so
it defines its vector
and it has the same dimensionality as
the hidden dimensions of the Hidden
State essentially and it defines for
each Dimension it defines how much
does the past matter
so for one dimension it could say well
the past matters a lot therefore
um that value is very high and for the
other dimension because I know that
value is very low the past doesn't
matter a lot what happens if we do that
ultimately we're going to do something
like
again something up here so you can see
we have e the exponential function of w
t i
plus k
I
um so
they now say okay we multiply this by
this term T minus I means how much back
I'm looking so if we wonder
we are token one
how much do we attend to or let's go the
other way around we're token four how
much do we attend to token number two
okay then we ask in which dimension in
the First Dimension or the First
Dimension is really large
um therefore we're going to attend a lot
to the the general past of Dimension One
okay
so maybe that's this drop off and then
we look two tokens in the past because
the current time step is four and this I
here is two so how
which token are we and which do we
attend to and you can see it's minus so
this is getting bigger and bigger as you
go further back in the past so it's
essentially a linear drop off
in the value of w and W itself can be
big or small and these two things
together Define how important a pass
token is in that particular Dimension so
it's a multiplication of how far back is
it and how much is this dimension in
general
considering its history and then you can
say ah it's considering this much it's
two tokens back so this much attention
and then that is modulatable Again by a
key value that can depend on exactly
what the current token is
I hope that's understandable the
attention Matrix is built on the fly in
rwkv and it's defined a by the vect it's
defined per dimension
the vector W defines a general
importance
list for each Dimension it defines how
relevant is the past
the second component is this it's simply
a linear Decay on in into the past so
the further back the less important it
is
that being said this is of obviously
then put through the exponential
function and therefore it's a linear
decay in the exponential function so I
guess an exponential decay
and then the third thing is the
modulation and this is where where this
is where the actual value that the
actual what the token is uh plays a role
is then to modulate that point we
determined right here modulated up or
down a little bit also in the in the
exponential function
so that is how rwkv considers the past
in general it forgets the past in an
exponential fashion modulated by the
global importance of dimensions and a
value that's dependent on the current
token
all right so it has the same trade-offs
as these attention-free Transformers
now what do we do with this with these
things somewhere we have we have sorry
for scrolling around so heavily
so this is how the model is composed
this is a recurrent application of the
model so we see the same model applied
to three tokens in succession so the my
name is
Bob okay you input my and you're trying
to make it output name then you input
name so you input my name you're trying
to make it output is then you input my
name is you're trying to make it output
Bob
so it's three applications of the same
model so the model isn't composed of
these three columns but the model is
composed of one column and then we just
apply that over and over again
you see it has a beginning essentially
which is a token embedding
um it has an end which is a language
modeling head which is a fully connected
or a stack of fully connected layers
that just Maps into the vocabulary but
in the be in the middle it's composed of
recurrent
or sorry of a series of layers so
there's in each layer there is always
sorry in each layer there's always a
time mix module and a channel mix module
so the time mix module being here and
the channel mix module being here and
those are repeated Timex Channel mix
time mix Channel mix and so on and then
on top there's this language modeling
head
so what are the two blocks this is a
schematic of how the two blocks look
like I know this is a bit small
um but the
time mixing is down here and the channel
mixing is down here we're gonna look at
this in a bit of detail in the math but
observe right here what you always have
is you have the input signal
you're going to compute R from it R is a
a value
that is going to be used as
for like a gate a forget gate so R
always defines how much of whatever is
incoming here or whatever is incoming
from here how much of that do I want to
retain and send up to the next layer
so as you can also see R is computed
over here as well
so for every one of these blocks we're
going to do a computation over here or
over here and then we're we're going to
have a decision made by this branch of
the computation of how much of that we
even want to accept and then send up to
the next layer
so that's the purpose of the left
branches of these computation there is
residual signal across all of these
things right here so that kind of mimics
the the state of of an lstm maybe but in
a in a in an upwards way so in a layer
to layer way so we always have a
residual model we also have a forget
gate in front of adding it to the
residual signal
what does the these two modules look
like so actually let's first go to the
channel mixing block the channel mixing
block is very reminiscent of
um kind of feed forward maybe layers so
what we have is ignore ignore this part
for a moment right here as I said the r
is computed from
the input X
and just a linear layer so x times a
matrix that's R so that's a linear layer
that defines R then we have K also x
times a matrix
it's a very simple feed forward layers
right here then W which is this part
right here that's no sorry v v is this
part right here
you can see that's a non-linearity and
the non-linearity here is the squared
relu the squared relu non-linearity on
top of K and again a linear layer and at
the end we're doing that element wise
multiplication by this this signal right
here so the r
uh pushed through the sigmoid here is
that forget gate that we talked about
but you can see it's a
essentially
if you follow if you follow the signal
through the actual path of signal
it starts here x well that's a funky
X
it's multiplied by a matrix so a linear
layer that becomes K that's put through
a non-linearity then multiplied by
another linear layer
that becomes the value V
and then send through the forget gate so
it's essentially
a feat for neural network with one
non-linearity and at the end I forget
gate as like another non-linearity
and that's it that's the channel mixing
module I guess it's Channel mixing
because this Matrix the the linear
layers they do in fact mix the channels
which means that every Dimension sort of
can get inputs from every other
dimension which is just a variety of a
feed forward Network now I've crossed
out all of this stuff in the back right
here so we should talk about this as
well
what they do is something called time
shift or token shift or
um I believe that's
one of them
token or time shift
and that is they always not only take
the input to the current layer at this
particular time step they also always
take the input from the last time step
and they linearly interpolate between
the two so you can see here mu and one
minus mu the MU and one minus mu are
either hyper parameters or their learned
parameters but they are per operation so
mu R here is a parameter for the general
computation of this R it's not dependent
on the particular data point only this
and this are dependent on the data point
with x t being the current input to the
layer and x t minus 1 being the last
step input to the layer this is pretty
interesting because it means that we not
only always only take the current input
and the hidden state from before like in
a general RNN but we always take the
current input the last input and for
this layer that's it but in the time
mixing module will then take the hidden
State onto these that's why in this
diagram you see these these lines right
here these diagonal lines
are the token shift lines so you see
this channel mix module is going to take
the current input whatever it gets from
the lower layers or the original signal
and the input to the last to the same
layer at the last time step
so current input and input to the last
time step and that also goes in these
two things are linearly interpolated and
that then is the input quote unquote to
the current layer so it's the
interpolation of the last step and this
steps input
no that's it's not like we don't mix
like the internal States right here we
mix the inputs before they go into the
layer
now let's look at the time mix you can
see there is also this token shift
happening so this token shift that's
just something you can do I guess if you
have a a one directional uh sequence
that you need to predict you can do this
token shifting but
what's also interesting is we have a
second line which are these states so
how does that work and that's going to
be now the actual recurrent part of this
model right here
you can again see here we're always
working with the token shift we never
just work with the input but you can
just think of these things here always
as like X sorry
X tilde where X tilde is a mix between
the current
input and the last layer's input
so we have we compute R which is just X
tilde times W Times a feed forward layer
and that again becomes the forget gate
down here with an element-wise
multiplication we do have an output
layer an output
sorry we do have an output feed forward
layer
kind of a projection that's I'm going to
guess they put that in because it was
advantageous to do so it can also change
the dimensionality in whatnot then we're
going to compute two things K and V so
you'll notice before whatever was called
V was produced from K but now both K and
V are produced from X
um I don't know why they call them the
same probably to keep as much in line
with the Transformer terminology as
possible but it's it's really there's no
relation between like the V here and the
V before the K is computed similarly so
this block right here the K and the V
are computed
module of the time shift
um as they are computed in the original
Transformer architecture
which is just the input times a linear
layer
then what happens is interesting then
as you can see right here we go into
this into this weighted sum so you'll
you'll see something familiar here
that's a weighted a weight and VT that's
the values so V we computed here so
we're going to look for a weighted sum
of the values B
but oh sorry no no no forget that
we're not only going to look for a
weighted sum of the value of e because
you also see here RVs but these are VI's
and this is VT the V I's in fact are the
past values
so we're going to look over for a
weighted sum across the entire
past and that's actually oh sorry it's
actually the same
um as before
yes
let me back up
so that I here only goes to T minus one
so you can see that we sum the VIS here
and then at the end we also sum the VT
the only reason that there is a
difference is this U right here is a
different parameter than those W's but
it's in essence it's again a weighted
sum over all the values and the values
are from the entire sequence
so so far we've just considered the
current time step the current input and
yes the last steps input but in this
step right here we consider the entire
past
and we want a weighted sum across the
values of the entire past like in these
attention-free Transformers and whatnot
but because we now no longer are limited
by having this fixed size uh this fixed
size attention Matrix right here even if
it's learned right even if it's not an
attention Matrix in the attention-free
Transformers it was still a fixed size
because we're no longer limited because
all we do is we say how important is
each dimension
and uh how does it decay with time in
the past
that does not is not limited back in
time it just gets really small back in
time but it is not limited and therefore
we can do this until perpetuity and
especially we can do it until I equals
one so going back to the very first
token so for every token that we need to
do inference for this step this value
right here will be a weighted sum across
the values of the entire past right and
you can see easily that you can do this
in a recurrent fashion this is a it's a
soft Max and you can see there is
exponentials that here and these are
multiplied by the values and down here
we go just over some of the exponentials
so 80 is a soft Max however you can just
keep track of the numerators and the
denominators separately and then that
that becomes your hidden State and you
can pass that forward so you just grab
this sorry right here and this down here
and before dividing them you just pass
them on right and then in the next step
you simply add some something on top
divide them for the current step but
then pass on the hidden States
separately so that's what they mean by
States if they say
they don't mean the United States I'm
sorry they mean these values here that
you need you can compute this in a
recurrent fashion or you can compute
this in a parallel fashion
so just to finish here quickly this
value here this weighted sum over all
the values of the past
is then
feet fed into this forget gate as you
see here and the output is computed from
it now multiple things to note right
here multiple things to note note that
the aggregation over the past here
contains essentially no non-linearity
right because
V
the thing that is being aggregated or in
general these hidden States they're just
produced as a linear function of a
linear interpolation of the inputs right
there is nowhere where the previous
state goes through a non-linearity in
order to compute the next hidden State
you can essentially track this as a
a big sum so as a list you can track it
as a list and then do the sum or you can
just track it as the sum which also
means that the parallelism of training
this becomes feasible again so you can
train these in parallel because it's
just all a big sum that you can compute
for an entire batch and an entire
sequence at the same time
and yes also you can use it in an RNN
fashion where you do it step by step but
because that's because it has no
non-linearities in between it's it
literally just a sum and that's also why
you why you see what I mean this is
essentially a convene and I mean
this it has two parts right the first
part is this stuff right here this token
shift look at the diagram in the diagram
you clearly see
if you are this element right here what
do you have access to you have access to
this
and this
oh about by extension you have access if
you just go via the token shift you have
access to this and this right and so
from the lower layer to this and this
right so by here so you have a receptive
field that grows with depth right if we
had another layer the receptive field
will grow again so the token shift
itself is already is sent it very
directly a convenant and you you know
you only have non-linearities as you
cross these layer boundaries right here
otherwise it's essentially just a linear
interpolation which is exactly a
convolution with the kernel being uh mu
and 1 minus mu that's your convolutional
kernel so size two you slide it over
um so that that defines a con
convolution and the same thing for these
things right here that is very
reminiscent of uh if you know about
these like S4 or state space models and
so on which essentially what they do is
they Define a way to linearly aggregate
the past
um which is exactly what this big sum is
right here they Define a way to do a
weighted sum across the past that in
between has no no non-linearities so you
can just track it like this and
yeah so
again and and S4 is essentially like a
big convolution
so if you want to think about this model
in another way than a Transformer or an
RNN not that they're not already enough
ways it's essentially a big con net
um in particular in in this way right
here it's a convenant that has sort of
an infinitely long convolution into the
past
um or until the beginning of the
sequence I guess
um and you the way it's done is there is
a standard con kernel and then that's
modulated by these K values right here
all right so that is
how that works I hope I've made this a
bit clearer
um the why this is called Channel mixing
and this one isn't called Channel mixing
like this is just as much Channel mixing
as the other one is the only difference
is that down here
um there is kind of a non-linearity
within the layer
and there is and and here we have this
aggregation over time so I guess calling
this time mixing is fair
but this is just as much Channel mixing
because
these feed forward layers they mix the
channels so
yeah but that's that's naming that
doesn't doesn't really matter so they
specify here this can be used in time
parallel mode
um complexity of processing a batch of
sequences in a single layer is this so
you can process a batch as a batch right
so it requires they say meanwhile
updating attention scores requires a
Serial scan and has a complexity of this
they've implemented this in a custom
Cuda kernel you can actually go look at
the code I've done that and it's fairly
easy to understand the Cuda code is one
of the more understandable pieces of
Cuda code
um and you you just write this function
Cuda takes care of sort of parallelizing
that and putting that across cores and
and workers and
processes and so on
the element wise computation is time
dependent but can be readily
parallelized along the other two
dimensions on the other hand you can
also use this as in a Time sequential
mode
um
can be conveniently formulated
recursively for decoding during
inference
oh oh
my connection here is spazzing out
one second
and we're back
yeah so they say each output token is
dependent only on the last state
which brings obviously all the
advantages and disadvantages of uh rnns
with it so again we can only consider
information coming through this
bottleneck of the Hidden state but I
feel because it's this big sum of
aggregation is essentially a weighted
sum across the past and not
non-linearity across non-linearity
across non-linearity it can much more
easily look back into the past in but it
can do so in a linear fashion right so I
feel this is among all the situations
like Transformer lstm and this one this
is probably the weakest form of being
able to look into the past with Nuance
right you can look into the past but you
can only do so in like a general fashion
whereas a Transformer can go look into
the past and have exactly the same
amount of detail as it does for the
recent past so you can look into the
long past as long as it's within the
context and do exactly the same
computation there as it can do for the
recent past or for the current token
whereas an lstm can't do that it can't
look into the past at all however it can
do a lot of considered computation in
each step before it saves it to the
hidden state so it's weaker because it
can't go back but still it can do a lot
of complex computation this model right
here it can look kind of it also goes
through the hidden state but it can look
the easiest much more easily into the
past as an lstm because it's just this
weighted sum instead of non-linearity
after non-linearity but it kind of has
the weakest form of computation that it
does in in the exact moment
I hope that makes a lot of sense that is
not a scientific statement that it's
just me trying to ramble
maybe I'm also totally wrong about this
or maybe you know you can easily make up
for that by stacking a lot of layers
because now this model is being able to
be stacked really heavily and be scaled
really heavily and that is probably
enough to make up for all the lack of
computation in the individual cell it's
just like a let's just stack the stuff
foreign
Ty that I have mentioned but is not
entirely maybe come through is the fact
that they always compute from the inputs
so they don't take they don't take
necessarily the
um the hidden States over so but all the
functions are like linear functions or
exponentials of linears of the inputs so
there's no like non-linearity in between
that time aggregation and the
um
and where and the inputs it's themselves
to the layer
sorry enough rambling here you can see
scaling behaviors
um very very beautiful cumulative time
during text generation as the tokens go
up obviously this model has a linear
scaling wherever everything else goes
the experimental evaluations are also
really interesting at least at the data
sets that they have considered right
here it can hold its own sometimes it's
a bit better sometimes it's a bit worse
than other similarly sized Transformers
but it um it performs along the same
lines now I have heard people say that
the model is qualitatively not as good I
have as Transformers of the same size
I've heard other people say it is better
or for some things it's better
that I don't know it still has to be
shown also these challenges or these
data sets right here don't really show
me what I would want to find out so if I
compare this to a Transformer what I
would want to find out is
how like where is the where then is the
actual difference right and I'm gonna
guess the difference is let's compare
something that is not in the recent past
but a bit more back now if I have to
consider something that is a bit more
back in the past and if that's a very
complex thing
whose or the computation of which like
how I have to treat that depends on the
current token
I can't really tell you now an example
for that but in a situation like this a
Transformer would be way Superior
um than like any lstm or or this model
right here so maybe during programming
in certain Fashions
um or if the context for something is
only given much later
but for a lot of applications probably
not that important they also can show
easily how increasing the context length
since they can do that now increasing
the context const context length uh
nicely decreases the loss of language
modeling on the pile data set and they
give some
um
some suggestions right here so for
example improving computational
efficiency by applying a parallel scan
in this step to reduce the computational
cost to this which would be another
Improvement that's theoretically
possible but I'm going to guess that's
not done right now
um
they also discuss the limitations so
they're very open about the limitations
and all the comparisons right here right
this is
um the linear attention leads to
significant efficiency gains but still
it may also limit the model's
performance on tasks that require
recalling minutiae minutiae information
over very long context okay that's
essentially what I was trying to
describe but it's it's done in much
better words than I did
the recurrent architecture inherently
limits its ability to look back at
previous tokens yeah that's like an RNN
and the they also discovered that there
is an increased importance of prompt
Engineering in comparison to standard
Transformer models so there are multiple
hypotheses the one they give right here
is the linear mechanism it limits the
information from The Prompt that will be
carried over to the model's continuation
as a result carefully designed prompts
may be even more crucial for the model
to perform well on tasks
um it could be it could be that that is
the reason there could also be other
reasons maybe this model
overfits a bit more or so or is less
generalizable and that's why changing
the prompt really matters more although
maybe not
I'm it's just one of these things where
there is probably a thousand possible
explanations of why with this model
the getting the prompt right really
matters a lot more than in a Transformer
but I wouldn't put my my bet on any one
of those until we have really good
experimental confirmation there's
usually a lot of
a lot of um
I should I say
there's a lot of Occam's razor that
should be done
all right the last thing I wanted to
show was this experiment right here
which I found really cool so uh the
first one is this time Decay so
communicate sort of long Channel axes
which is where you can see the the
difference
um so here is the channel this is the
dimension right this is the dimension
we're looking at w right here this
Vector W how important is the past in
layer one you can see as far as I can
tell the past is not that important
so for many of the channels the past is
kind of for some of the channels so it's
sorted by that value so for some of the
channels the past is important for Mo
for a lot of them it's really not really
not important and you can see as you go
up the layers of this network they more
and more and more consider the past
um
and then what's interesting is the
drop-off right here so you have some
channels really specializing in
near-term information but a lot of
channels really looking back at at the
the long time into the back so the W
will Define almost no drop off uh
whereas at the in the lower layers
um you have much more local information
that the thing considers so I found that
pretty cool to see that visualized and
to see that progression as in a trained
model As you move up the layers the
second visualization here it's
um an example so here you have a input
of tokens the Eiffel Tower is located in
the city of and then they look at How
likely is the word Paris right here
and what they do is they
change
in each layer they change in each layer
um they swap out the weights or they
disturb the weights and they see how
much influence does that have on the
probability of the word Paris appearing
this is a way we've previously looked at
that in the paper on Rome I believe was
the technique where you can it's a way
to figure out
um what are the important information
paths that you're considering so in this
case you can clearly see
after the I fell we see that layers one
to like 20 or so light up right and
after that it's what's what's cool is
so after that
only layers whatever 21 22 and 23 Light
Up Until the End right here so only
these light up which means that you can
you can disturb these lower layers right
here because the information that Paris
should probably is a very likely word
has already passed from the lower layers
to the higher layers right all the way
up and is then stored and carried along
in the hidden states of these higher
layers across these tokens such that the
information in the lower layers is only
mildly relevant
um to the output right here of course it
is relevant there is not zero values
right here but it is
mildly mildly relevant
so I thought that was a pretty cool
visualization of what was going on in
this model let me quickly scroll through
and see if I forgot anything I did not
there are some examples at the end which
is pretty cool
um the models are available you can go
check them out you can go test them the
Code base is also I found it to be
fairly understandable so if you want to
go look at that it's also available and
yes my
thing is spasming out again that's where
I'll end it uh go check out fully
connected
um again code is in the description to
get you some discount if you're in San
Francisco June 7th I unfortunately will
not be there but many many many many
cool people will be that was it thank
you bye-bye